well it looks like venom and carnage are
going to have some company in the
upcoming venom two film what's up
everybody it's Warren and today we have
some big news in regards to the venom
sequel that is coming out on October 2nd
2020
it appears that Eddie Brock and the
Venom symbiote are going to have to deal
with a second villain in the film and
the second villain is somewhat of a
mutant from Marvel but it makes perfect
sense that this villain is going to be
in venom too so let's break down this
report quick reminder to subscribe to my
channel if you'd like a chance to win at
Xbox one or a ps4 and be sure to like
the video and comment down below now at
the end of venom we saw Eddie Brock go
into a prison cell where he spoke to
Cletus Kasady we see a notebook that
Eddie Brock has that says how violent
and crazy Cletus Kasady is and right
before Eddie leaves Cletus drops the
bomb and says when I get out there will
be carnage very obviously setting up the
next villain for the next venom movie
carnage so we've known that carnage was
going to be the villain of the venom
sequel for some time now however we did
not know that he would have company and
according to a report from deadline.com
his company is going to take the form of
shriek now not many people know who
shriek is but the fact that she is
coming along with carnage makes perfect
sense shrieks debut in the comics is in
the maximum carnage crossover a fan
favorite when carnage escaped from the
Ravencroft mental institution he came
across shriek who was also incarcerated
shriek wished to join carnage so carnage
set her free and the two of them went
off on a very violent killing spree
together
so as you can see it's not that big of a
surprise that she is going to be
introduced in venom 2 now as I mentioned
she is a mutant her powers come from the
latent mutant gene that is in her shriek
starts off as a criminal she's a drug
dealer and during her time of crime a
police officer ends up shooting her in
the head
but cloak puts her in his dark force
dimension which ends up awakening her
latent mutant abilities which include a
few things for starters she can fly she
also has the ability of sound
manipulation she can shield herself with
a sonic field and shoot sonic energy
blasts from her hands and not to mention
she has the ability to tap into people's
minds and bring
their inner darkness fear anger hate
someone and so forth making them act
insanely violent which kind of leads us
into another theory about how venom and
spider-man could face off against one
another yesterday we got confirmation
from the writer of venom that venom is
heading towards the direction of having
him face off against spider-man and the
question right now is how are they going
to face off against one another or why
if somebody going to pin them up against
each other kind of like a Batman vs
Superman type of thing or is venom and
Eddie truly going to go insane because
if that is the case shriek could
definitely make that happen it's one of
her mutant abilities but we know at the
end of the day venom and spider-man will
most likely be allies after they go up
against each other they'll both realize
that they're both good guys for the most
part and that works out really well
because carnage is a lot stronger than
venom and he's going to have the help of
shreak venom is not going to be able to
take on both of them alone he's going to
need the help of spider-man and based
off of recent information that we've
learned venom is leading towards
spider-man appearing in the movie so
could perhaps venom to have spider-man
in it we know that it is eventually
coming but could spider-man come that
early in venom 2 we're going to have to
wait and see to find out but in the
meantime let me know what you think
about shriek being a new villain in
venom - be sure to let me know in the
comments down below also don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to my
channel so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to venom and
spider-man and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 I'm picking a new winner at
five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers be sure to follow me on
Instagram and Twitter as well I'm
starting up and you giveaway there soon
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof